hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play the world's
hardest game - because I'm a haha hi
what's the expression I I hate myself is
that the expression that I'm looking for
I'm a glutton for punishment that's what
I was looking for yeah so I'm here with
the world's hardest game version - this
is the official sequel to the game that
I played earlier presented by bla bla
bla
who cares about that just get to the
pain and suffering that I'm about to
experience let's get it give it give it
okay so we're in the game and we're
gonna have so much fun I can't even
begin to describe how much I'm looking
forward to this I do not need a tutorial
I know how to play back knew what
continue there we go okay there we go
you don't stand a chance
well you don't know my levels of skill
and perseverance in the face of
adversity oh oh oh so easy I can't even
begin to describe ba ba I I asked for
that my I can't even begin to describe
my skill and perseverance in the face of
adversity
uh Jerry they're going into it right off
the bat I didn't even contact okay
alright so the key to beating these sort
of games is to first be good at video
games which I'm already I'm already Sol
out of that you must be kidding me whoa
but you obviously don't mean no me cuz I
never kid I would never kid anyone at
all cuz you gah wait a minute what
that's not enough room to go out oh I
get it I get it I'm done I'm done I'm
done I went
I'm dumb I'm dumb dumb dumb just puts up
yeah but to follow it so you can do that
yeah just like that
Oh what now biznitch am I supposed to
follow their I don't think so
well yes I have to write or do i by the
time I get there it'd be too late oh my
god let's go boy ah I died
fudge oh man most of this is just gonna
be trial and error until I decide to rip
out all my hair and throw myself out of
my window I did that before what do you
tell what you're talking about game well
would with you but what you talk about
ah ah touch it I didn't touch it you all
saw I've got it on camera you all see
from the camera that I am too pro for
this game to be beaten by I did that
before why why just add insult to injury
every time I die in this game I'm gonna
punch myself in the penis until I learn
oh come on what that was bull you are
this game is rigged this game frigged
it's just why I did this before I swear
is there like a sprint button to make my
little square move his non-existent legs
or do I do I just have to punch him no
that's a trick can't just gotta go
oh come on how can I be this bad this er
oh I didn't even touch it
alright I've said that too many time I
just gotta be Oh No maybe maybe not even
going that room maybe
it's a trick it's all a trick it's a
trick C trick I don't even need to go
see where do you stop
well I can't do that either because
punch sickle oh come on I've racked up
18 deaths I'm on the third level I am at
the disadvantage I've never played the
second version no no damn at da bat ah
fudge how did I get there the first time
this is impossible
oh god how do I keep misjudging that I'm
not doing this on purpose guys I'm not
doing this on purpose
I swear I'm really trying here
oh come on holy balls I'm going to I'm
gonna turn into there we go
I did it that time now how the hell do I
do Drive
our dad our dad I get it I'm gonna do it
oh crap ah yeah buddy whoa
number one what the hell is that that a
key and what the hell is going on there
what kind of what kind of [ __ ] shows all
this well there this blows to be hello
my brain is having trouble wrapping
Tahoma god my brain is not gonna be only
word Georgia now I actually known that
those obvious now those toes my bad
that was me that was on me I was on me
ah something oh come on
there's my opening there's my opening
okay got that then who'd I know who do
you know I always it I don't even hit
the fast-moving ones I was so stupid oh
come on I walked right into that man my
brain go go I try how many strange
noises can mark a bar make no okay
just bear with me everybody I'm gonna
piss picker with me cuz you you need to
have a lot of patience with me oh yeah
oh yeah who's the man now okay so I'm in
a safe zone over here
they don't come all the way over and I
can just go in my own time
ah ha ha ha I sighs ah
man oh lordy Lordy loo I can't do this
Lola loo okay let's just go Joe ah ah I
care for some reason I'm paying so much
attention to the horizontal ones that I
don't see the stupid oh that was dumb
yeah that wasn't my fault no that wasn't
my fault either
none of these deaths are my fault and
might I add you try talking into a
camera at a thousand words per minute
and playing these games at the same time
you try doing actual commentary you know
why professional gamers don't talk when
they're doing their [ __ ] and because
they're I'm real I'm not bad you all
think I'm bad but I keep see watch this
I'm gonna be in total silence for this
next one and you're all gonna see just
how amazing of a gamer I really am for
any minute now I'm gonna shut up and
he's second now
okay this time total silence ha ha
goddamnit
ah it's like my brain is like engaged in
commentary at all times and decide what
huh well you've had to do there buddy oh
you try to focus now why don't you say
give another dick joke that's what the
people love that's what the kiddies out
now I wanna hear get dick jokes all day
long ha ha always fun build more penises
and drunk minecraft that really gets it
going or yeah quality entertainment kind
of whole family can sit around the fire
and enjoy ha ha ok
uh-uh I don't know where I went wrong
with my life that I keep hitting the
same damn thing over and over and over
and over and over and over and over
again so let's do this less stupidly who
Donna I see it gumming hi I just said I
do nothing about it
god this is what it's come to really
just let me out of here I want to not
die oh whoa king of the road why don't I
have checkpoints it were checkpoints in
the other game well I just look at this
I can do this cuz I've done this before
no no no not then bad time
okay go now and then whoosh ha oh it's
even more insulting when I have to go
all the way back to the beginning this
really is I swear the world's hardest
game but there is like who it would take
so much practice to be able to do this
on the first try cuz I mean it's
deceptive because it may seem like it's
cycles but there's actually specific
timings that you have to obey or else
you will get sandwiched in and there's
nothing that you can do about Lexi there
it's all on different rhythms and wall
that was just me that was me being dumb
as stupid ass and not being able to do
anything coordinated with my na ha whoa
whoa you almost got me there buckaroo oh
you almost got me there pardner oh okay
so we're bad suckas just need to do the
same thing to get to the next green area
and that's all there is to it I mean
it's not that complicated okay go go
drop okay go yeah yeah level four done
of fifty how could they get I know that
wasn't that hard I just could not wrap
my brain around the different movements
I'm not stupid I'm not done some pretty
dumb apparently I'm different timeless
I'm a different type of smart oh my god
what is going on aah aah aah aah
No I had it
aah how did Oh like every single time I
go it is the first time I do it it's
just plain dumb luck and I'm able to go
through it and then the sequential times
is just move mm-hmm
what you wanted to do coordinated
movements how about you run straight
into it how about that oh oh you want to
do oh I'm so sorry I'm so sorry friend
I'm so sorry buddy you can't do that
you're not allowed to be good no one's
allowed to be good in this place here's
where hopes and dreams go to die just
like everything you ever cared about
because you're gonna end up killing it
yep what dad would ha ha ha who's too
pro this guy this guy's too bro to pro I
they should lock me up in a pro facility
Oh God
how about a screwed up here I just hang
on everybody shut up shut up shut up for
a second everybody just shut up shut up
hey Jimmy
shut up Rebecca I swear to God shut up
don't give me that lip don't I don't
even care jack you shut up I know it
you all won't listen Becky shut up okay
odd new
I can do this it's not that hard but I
haven't getting into it getting out of
that was hard enough I just getting into
it is gonna be a nightmare
okay here we go here we go here we go
here we go yes yes yeah see what happens
when you all just Shh and be done what
how is that even possible
let's know the route to go there's no
other route route what what is this Wow
come on Wow we're not gonna make it no
we made it oh my god I can't believe
that worked
oh we're not gonna make this one ah ha
ha renovate Oh No yeah who the man who
the man who the man what a man what a
man I know and I am the man ha ha hey I
don't need any of that sash wait a
minute
there's a trick to this level isn't
there there's some this one's a more
colligate I bet you so you can't just
you're not gonna be able to dude no not
if you run into him you can't can you
it's impossible yeah so you gotta go
down oh well you gotta go duh yeah okay
safe zones you up
aha Oh punched in the dick good wiggle
with a everybody dance everybody dance
air raid yes Michael start dancing
okay now get to seriousness
hup-hup yeah you're damn at yeah I need
everybody's dance powers to coordinate
and focus so that I can get through this
because there's no other way besides
your rhythmic movements I will not be
able to succeed yeah I do yeah yeah I'm
great
I know I know baby I'm great I'm the
best I thought I was gonna get me but
I'm the I'm too I'm too good to be got
yeah some people say have a good Joker
laughs was that good was that a good one
Heath Ledger Joker yeah dude
yabba-doo chi mandingo yeah be loose ki
bodge yo Titan to someone from another
country just recently and I used the
expression cool beans and they were like
flabbergasted they're like what the hell
did you just say I said cool beans you
know cool bean man
no one said cool beans where you're from
everybody in America says cool beans
right who says cool beans all right
everybody that's what I thought
everybody else is weird we're not weird
yeah Hadj
oh okay get this one more because I'm
just too stupid to realize where the
safe zones are they're actually not as
far down as I think they are but if I go
too far then I get smacked in the balls
happen douche pepper
yeah bus scoop flabby aha I give up I'm
done this is too much too much for my
little brain to handle you can't skip
levels so this is it that's it that's
all I can do seven levels out of 50 good
luck everybody else you're gonna need it
so it's your turn now to embarrass
yourself why don't you record a video
and try to do commentary at the same
damn time think up amazing jokes like oh
yeah [ __ ] joke ha ha I make stupid joke
yeah anyone could do what I do I'm not
nothing special
anyway thank you all so much for
watching if you got another impossible
game that you want me to play write in
the comments below so thanks again and
as always I will see you
or in the next video am I
normale
Oh
but